mon invention préféré c'est la crème
antirides parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison que les hommes puissent pas
besoin d'eux merci alex pour ce
témoignage édifiant même si c'était le
dernier épisode ce bas je sais mais cela
que je voulais faire moi c'est vrai
qu'ils étaient pas mal toujours un train
de retard t'inquiète on va bien trouver
un truc à faire ensemble quoi celui à
celui d'aujourd'hui oh bah je sais pas
je voulais parler des stéroïdes
aujourd'hui cette chauffe comme c'est
l'été ou alors on observait étoiles tout
ça de cailly mieux les cailloux à bout
de bras as tu vu ce que tu fais détient
une solution je dois les cuisses avec
valentine on m'a appelé bonjour humaine
elle aussi tu vas essayer de la butte et
je suis fait de silicium j'ai une
admiration sans limites pour les
géologues c'est la seule science que
peuvent comprendre vos esprits primitif
on va plus
merci il ya ne prend pas trop la
confiance quand même sportura l'ex
[Musique]
bonjour valentine bonjour ph est-ce que
les cas il de l'espace sont les mêmes
que ceux qu'on trouve sur terre oui et
non ces cailloux ont-ils une spécificité
spécifiques ah oui assurément et où
peut-on voir ces camions dans l'espace
essentiellement et sur terre quand ils
tombent chez nous et bien merci
valentine ces quelques secondes en sa
compagnie ont une nouvelle fois était
des plus médiocres à jamais ah oui à
jamais avec plaisir
merci d'avoir regarder cet épisode
jusqu'au bout like et enfin ou pop ce
que non la cote des filles [ __ ]
sérieuse mais les quais ou savons déjà
pas du rêve mais franchement vous faites
un effort pour vous supporter 10 minutes
ben je sais pas tu veux savoir que moi
rien au foot c'est toujours l'été les
soirées à mater les étoiles et en ce
moment le temps idéal pour pécho sous
couvert de forums antiques pas pardon le
temps idéal pour mater les étoiles
filantes les perséides phone pour se la
péter un petit peu id les perséphone id
n'ont plus cours les ide en plus longs
les perséides oui ça marche mieux alors
oui la vidéo devait sortir la semaine
dernière au moment idéal pour les
observer mais déjà jeté à la montagne
pas de pollution lumineuse mais sous la
flotte quasiment tous les soirs mais on
s'en fout de ta vie ou remarques tout à
fait désobligeant tu encore une fois
mais forte à propos néanmoins en effet
ma vie ma météo balech mais il y avait
un autre souci plus universel ton
existence la lune elle était pleine la
semaine dernière ce qui ne permet pas
une observation astronomique des plus
qualitative ceci dit si tout le monde
est rentré de vacances en ville pas sûr
que ce soit beaucoup mieux mais bref
alors première question pourquoi qu'on
voit les étoiles filantes spécialement à
cette date vous le savez si vous êtes
nés après nicolas copernic la terre
tourne autour du soleil et forcément
quand on tourne autour d'un truc on
finit fatalement par repasser par les
mêmes endroits si tu fais six tours de
la foire festoient la fête de l'oie à
sarlat tu vas à un moment ou un autre
repasser par le stand de churros c'est
inévitable bon eh bien là c'est pareil
chaque année la terre fait son petit
tour et repasse par un nuage de
poussière qu'on appelle les perséides
donc ce sont des petits blocs de roche
laissées par la comète 109 paix swift
tuttle découvre par lewis swift et
horace parnell de tonnes chacun de leur
côté indépendamment en juillet 1856 et
donc on lui a donné les deux noeuds puis
re découverte en 1992 par solo ico
kiuchi qui lui est bien bien aller se
faire [ __ ] pour le non la comète swift
tuttle à une orbite d'environ 133 ans ça
varie un peu la trajectoire est complexe
mais retenez juste cent trente trois ans
et qu'elle repassera en 2126 et qu'on
pourra la mater halloween il faudra
faudrait sur le coup et puisqu'on est à
peu près dans les approximations bien
entendu c'est pas juste ce soir qu'on va
pouvoir voir les étoiles filantes mais
c'est à peu près sur un mois vous vous
doutez bien que un nuage de poussière
c'est pas juste un petit mur parce que
oui comme quand tu invites ian chez what
pour un petit week end shield la comète
et laisse traîner derrière elle tout un
tas de merde your partant tout à fait
des rushs des fragments dans le cas de
la comète des bières et des filles de
petite vertu dans le cas de yann mais
c'est pas le sujet de la vidéo on peut
pas avoir ces traces à lui dans le ciel
par contre on peut voir mes traces à moi
sur les filles
bref la terre passe dans cet amas de
poussière qui vont dans un sens et nous
dans l'autre et comme les nonces très
bien le principe physique dit de l'arbre
et de paul walker si deux corps allant
dans des directions différentes décidé
d'occuper le même espace au même instant
ça fait les roches entre en résistance
avec l'atmosphère à très vive allure
elle se consume dans l'air en créant des
traînées tellement pipe ou qu'il faut
faire un peu quel rapport entre l'icône
est et les autres poulets les joues le
rapport c'est les jeux et heureusement
qu'il y à l'atmosphère pour créer cette
barrière parce que ben déjà je vous
rappelle que si vous enlevez l'ère du
ciel les oiseaux tombent merci j c mais
en plus sans ça elle pourrait nous
tomber sur la courge sans prévenir à 700
fois la vitesse du son je me permets
d'insister sur un truc pour ce qu aurait
pas fait gaffe c'est que oui la plupart
des étoiles filantes convoi en fait
c'est des poussières
voilà ça vous fait une belle jambe il
n'ya pas qu'on doute qu'on peut profiter
de cette fameuse plus d'étoilés filantes
en novembre aussi par exemple on
traverse un autre nuage les léonides
même principe la commet le nuage de
reste mais on va pas détailler ici parce
qu'on s'en fout par contre très
important il ne faut pas confondre
comètes et astéroïdes
non non
déjà on va s'accorder sur le vocabulaire
parce que jusque là je parlais étoiles
filantes mais c'est pas très pro 1 on
dirait un bouquin de ma fille un
astéroïde c'est un caillou qui se
baladent pelouse a priori le truc est là
au moins il n'aura jamais la moindre
flatulences sur ta vie ni toit sur la
sienne un astéroïde c'est juste un autre
corps céleste est un astéroïde ça en
gros la même composition chimique que la
terre on va y revenir et d'ailleurs à
qu'on va y revenir j'ai dit c'est pas
encore à toi tu me censure parce que
chez une femme c'est ça dont ils ne
commettent al'inverse c'est élégant
majestueux c'est le blond des trucs qui
se baladent là où elles sont composées
de métaux et de roches comme les
astéroïdes mais aussi de glace et de
matières organiques une hypothèse avance
même que ce serait les comètes qui ont
apporté les premières formes de vie sur
terre al'approche du soleil la glace
fond ce sublime comme moi ce qui donne
cette traînée blanche caractéristique
et au passage elle perd aussi des
morceaux plus solide qu'on retrouve donc
dans le ciel les soirs d'été une
météorite c'est un truc un astéroïde
poussière de comètes sandra bullock qui
tombe sur terre à parlant de météorites
on en connaît deux grands types d'une
part les météorites non différenciées où
tout est en vrac un c'est vraiment le
puzzle quand on ouvre la boîte notre
bonne vieille planète est constitué de
toutes ces conneries tu sais le nom pour
se la péter dans les milieux autorisés
qui se sont réarrangés avec le temps les
éléments les plus lourds comme le fer
vont percolé peu à peu vers le centre 1
pour donner le noyau si maintenant la
terre se prend un impact et qu'elle est
ternie du matériaux rocheux vers
l'espace et ben pas on m'a le deuxième
type de météorique les météorites
différencier dans celle là on ne
retrouve qu'une certaine partie du
matériel de dans celui de la croûte ou
bien du manteau ou bien du noyau si
votre planète est complètement éclatée
par l'impact ça c'est votre petit neveu
qui choque votre puzzle tout finit tout
beau et qui l'envoie se fracasser contre
un mur les petits morceaux de pièces en
chasser les unes dans les autres et ben
c'est ça les météorites différencié pour
en savoir plus n'hésitez pas à aller
voir mon épisode du vortex en
descriptions vas-y foetale pub pas de
souci bah oui écoute ça comme tu me
payes pas pour cette vidéo faut bien que
je me rémunère en visibilité et en
parlant de palper un n'oubliez pas que
vous pouvez soutenir là chaîne via utile
et hippie merci encore à tous ceux qui
donnent de manière régulière
exceptionnelle ça m'aide tellement à
bosser plus sereinement donc merci
encore mille fois vous pouvez aussi
aller faire un tour sur red bull vous
pouvez commander un de mes t-shirts de
tasses sacs en tissus et autres
réjouissances confectionné par mes soins
pour vous faire plaisir expression à la
mode ces derniers temps c'est une source
de revenus non négligeable pour une
petite chaîne ne pas encore 100 mille
abonnés
ah ok donc sa part déjà en mode fort à
elle est belle la science sinon j'ai
aussi invité on peut retrouver les lieux
d'un impact de météorite sur wikipédia
et sur l'excellente appli de voyages
trop seul comme à rochechouart et
chassenon en haute-vienne et charente où
les mecs ont carrément construit des
bâtiments en impact it des roches
terrestres qui se sont mangés une bonne
callas de sa grand mère dans l'âme ou et
et qui ont été modifiées par la chaleur
et la pression de l'impact est projeté
alentours cet impact la date de plus de
200 millions d'années donc le cratère a
disparu mais ces traces de reste dans
les monuments salsa en analysant leurs
compositions qui est plus riche en fer
notamment que les roches alentours et
puis certaines roches ont été
transformés par un pacte ce qui peut
donner des trucs sympas comme des
gouttes de verre ou du quartz choqué il
en a vu des choses mais un caillou s'il
est suffisamment gros peut aussi éclatés
se fracasser contre l'eire comme atout
mouska et se fracturait avant l'impact
avec le sol plein de morceaux vont voler
et s'éparpiller partout alentour un tel
un agent smith trop confiant à plusieurs
dizaines voire centaines de kilomètres
mène et enfin un météore c'est comme une
météorite mais qui loupé sa cible le
truc ne touche jamais le sol c'est
pourquoi cia est vraiment le chevalier
de bronze le plus éclaté avec cpt hors
de mes gaz le parlant les météores de
pégase salut sydney merci pour la mer
contrepèterie du monde puisque par
définition ils ne touchent pas leur
cible ah oui on entend aussi parler de
bolides bon bah c'est juste des gros
météo ou météorite qui traversent
l'atmosphère un truc bien fatos bien
vénère et brillant qui va faire la joie
des tic toc heures du monde entier
souvent russe des rg pas pourquoi eux
plus que les autres
ça c'est parce qu'ils ont tous des
d'ashkan dans leur voiture c'est pour
l'assurance du coup ils peuvent filmer
ce genre d'événements sans problème
alors que toi le temps que tu sors ton
téléphone avec tes gros doivent dîner
actu chausse ses lunettes devient le
truc il est passé il a eu le temps
d'aller pulvérisé une station balnéaire
afghane et toi tu auras pas tes millions
dus c'est triste les météorites nous
renseigne sur l'histoire de notre
planète et les autres aussi on vient
tous de ces mêmes cailloux bah oui on
est constitué de reste des toiles
mourante qui se sont agglomérés en
cailloux spatiaux cailloux qui ont fini
par former des planètes planète sur
laquelle tout petits organismes
gesticule constitué de briques
élémentaires formé à partir de ce que
ces cailloux on à offrir ni plus ni
moins d'ailleurs pour la petite histoire
jusqu'au xviiie siècle les mecs
n'avaient pas la moindre idée de ce que
pouvait être ces manifestations
lumineuse dans le ciel ce qui faisait
dire que ça pouvait des cailloux extra
terrestre était pris pour desquels des
fous pour les gens du nord on pensait
que c'était des roches volcaniques
généralement où des manifestations
divine les cailles aux extraterrestres
qu'on retrouve et on les confie à
l'église du coup le vatican on a une
collection du fou ou alors vous pouvez
aussi prendre ça pour de mauvais
présages d'où le voeu qu'il fallait
faire pour pas choper le et probablement
après on se prend quand même cinq mille
tonnes de poussière et de cailloux
spatiaux sur la surface de la terre
chaque année ça reste conséquent même si
c'est vrai un compte en parle de plus
ces quelques cailloux à leur convoi et
en plus de ça la plupart ne touchent
même pas le sol ce sont juste des
poussières donc voilà il tombe pas eu
non plus entre les tartines tous les
quatre matins et tant mieux parce que si
c'est chiant à construire maison est
comme tout le monde le sait bambou les
chances de traverser un champ
d'astéroïdes avec succès sont
approximativement 2 1 sur 3720 le hockey
très bien mais merci pour cette
information capitale mais du coup là on
traverse un champ d'astéroïdes tous les
ans
c'est fonction de la taille du vaisseau
quel type de champ d'astéroïdes
parce que oui en vrai c'est cool pour le
cinéma mais c'est pas du tout comme ça
un vrai champ d'astéroïdes s'est jamais
aussi rapproché sinon les cailloux se
colleraient entre par contre la
probabilité de s'en prendre un sur la
courge est vraiment infime 1 commence et
pape sy côté c'est pas utile elle
pourrait détruire une maison c'est une
possibilité et en parlant de don't look
up dans la vraie vie il ya effectivement
des projets en cours d'étude pour les
mines et les ressources incroyables de
certains astéroïdes - des comètes c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué logistiquement
pour aller se poser sur des engins
pareil avec la poussière et tout un on
n'est pas dans cette immense merde
d'armageddon ou su foule mais je vais en
reparler bientôt est pareil un épisode
dédié 1 sur comment se protéger en cas
de contacts potentiels avec ce que nous
appelons un exterminateur ah bah
maintenant que j'ai commencé à vous
parler de spatiale je vais plus vous
lâcher conserver des étoiles fait un
voeu ou pas quand une étoile filante
passe pas la peine de vous demander si
ça vient d'un astéroïde ou d'une comète
juste profiter du spectacle c'est beau
c'est romantique ça fait partie des
spectacles les plus incroyables de la
nature ça fait partie de nous
littéralement on est tous constitués de
cette poussière des toits la loi pour
poster de chatons
merci encore une fois à mes acolytes
pour tout ça merci à valentine la athéna
de l'humour et de la folie sur youtube
j'arrête pas de le dire à voir sa chaîne
merci à nathan eût été utile et merci à
nathan et bambou le chat sceptiques
d'être venu passer une tête promis c'est
le seul chat que vous verrez sur cette
chaîne lever les yeux au ciel et je ne
vais pas finir cette phrase parce que
vous l'avez déjà tous en tête
le génie est partout
[Musique]
m